I said this the other day to our group I
said listen when you go from employee to
wanting to take the next step before
entrepreneurship the first thing you got
to do is you gotta learn how to sell
yeah no matter what it is you gotta
learn how to sell then after selling you
gotta learn how to manage salespeople
because some people know how to solve
most people don't have a clue how to
manage sales but how do you drive them
how do you create contests initiatives
comp you know compensation plan that's
work after sales manager you become a
business owner after business owner you
start thinking like a CEO then it goes
to the next level of investor etc etc
yeah but you learn if a person can go
past the sales side and some guys can
look at LeBron LeBron James was playing
for Cleveland he comes in the game he's
dominating the game yeah no one's come
up with 25 points per season yeah seven
assists seven rebounds per hour on
playoffs and then he decides to go to
Miami now watch this
a lot of people may disagree with this
the Alpha in Miami is not LeBron the
Alpha is Dwyane Wade the guy that can
take the last shot is Dwayne Wade
Stephen a Smith says LeBrons good for
the first 46 minutes the last two
minutes I want somebody else he knew he
needed somebody else
he went to got to Championships look at
Cleveland right now they won last year
when the pressure was on the point
somebody knew to make the shot it was
Kyrie Irving yeah yeah he took the shot
they won the championship yeah so you
look at that in the world of
entrepreneurship like Tom Ellsworth who
is not a president of PHP Tom's back Ron
he was on our board for six years now
you had Tom yeah you did good I'm so
jammed that with seven other people for
680 million dollars to EA Sports Wow Tom
became to see of go TV then he found a
premier digital publishing I think he
sold it to Thomas Nelson and then when
he came town I said Tom want you coming
here says Pat I figured out one thing
listen what this guy says he says I make
the best number two for company I'm not
a good number one look how difficult it
is for somebody to be so self-aware that
they know I'm a great number two right
right
respect I like weight having a pressure
at the last minute I like I really have
an oppressor at the last minute I'm
gonna mean there's something in
basketball there's something about the
team putting all this attention on
LeBron and making it easy for another
guy that shot Ryan your bed is here a
hundred dollars because you're LeBron
guy no no no no no because because I
think what you're LeBron guy you can see
it everyone's watching I just won is the
action is a LeBron of course easy action